[Music]
i became leader in june 3rd of june i
was uh born in a small village outside
of favisham i went to work in london
i was elected in 2015
and
i was re-elected again in 2019. i've
played the sport all my life i think
sports really important i play
football for south england played hockey
for
handball and cliftonville and i play
golf now at northland and had been
played at westgate
being the leader i mean i had to hit the
ground running obviously it's not easy
when you come in mid-term the main thing
really is that i like to get out and
meet the people to see what the
communities are up to
i treat the residents of sanet in the
way that i used to in my previous jobs
the shareholders we were accountable to
shareholders and i sort of
think of residents as
shareholders of
of the district
my main focus is on
um
trying to
leverage as much inward investment into
the thana area because i believe that
we've got some golden opportunities here
and we have to get that investment in
that's the whole point of the government
with the
with the leveling up funds with the
margate town deal with the high street
funds
this is just really to show
the big investors that look the
government's willing to invest in it and
only
a couple of weeks ago
i met along with the
mp and the deputy leader
the secretary of state
robert generic came here we met him at
the station we walked in along the
seafront we showed him the old town we
walked up the high street
and just exampled about how this is the
sort of area that the money the
government are injecting will help
i recently went to ramsgate football
club who were running the
hab programme
it was quite humbling when i walked in
there
and there's all 200 children all running
about in there and it's quite humbling
to think that you know this is all going
on and
and i don't think people quite realize
how much effort you know what they put
into it to run it to run these clubs and
there's a lot of the community that come
together with that there's and the
community in thana is fantastic you know
we have people that go out and regularly
litter pick
um they're all unsung heroes you know
and unpaid heroes but they just like
their area to look good
[Music]
very early in my um
role as leader was the major incident
with southern water occurred with the
failure of the fullness pumping station
and like all the residents and the
businesses of thanet i was totally
outraged at
that this had happened yet again
so
on the sunday following um i said to my
wife i'm going to write to the chief
executive of southern water and just
tell him exactly how i feel
and
demand that he comes down to a meeting
i
basically demanded not what
what i would call compensation but i
just felt that
as a gesture of goodwill to senate
district council and the distress that
it's caused the the area
um that i felt that they should make a
compensation payment so um
that has was agreed and i'm pleased to
say that the funds have been transferred
into the thani district council's
account and
that has been ring fenced and i will put
that to to good to good causes within
margate ramsgate and broadstairs to the
benefit of the residents i also asked
for um the
chief executive of southern water to
come and address a member's briefing
which he did on monday
and um
again it was um
he was a he was able to answer the
questions that
that members obviously have been asking
since the incident i think that it was a
it was a good and constructive meeting
and also he outlined the southern waters
plans for the um infrastructure and the
improvements to the infrastructure for
thanning
so that hopefully we don't ever have to
experience this again
[Music]